- Hi I'm Gaten Matarazzo.
- I'm Joe Keery.
- And I'm Maya Hawke.
- And we're going through a
scene from Stranger Things
on Netflix.
- Shot by shot.
(dramatic music)
- Okay, clear.
Clear, come on let's go.
- Okay that was close.
(mouse click)
- I guess the first thing I remember
is being squished behind this--
- [Maya] There's no room back there,
and there had to be four people.
- Thank god I got no collar bones
because I was just like
squished on in there
(laughter)
like woo!
(mouse click)
- Too close.
- Relax.
Alright relax, nobody saw--
(announcement)
(mouse click)
- We're in a warehouse.
- This is a totally built set.
Yeah, this is a warehouse that they have--
- In a really janky part of town.
(laughter)
- Behind all of these
walls is just plywood,
I mean it really does
look like it was filmed
on some sort of location
but they built everything
from the ground up.
- This next shot I
believe is what we called
the Scooby-Doo shot.
(laughter)
- Yes.
(mouse click)
(dramatic music)
- That also does look pretty Scooby-Doo.
- No this was also Scooby-Doo,
it was like the, (gasp) shot
- If we are Scooby-Doo, which ones are we?
- We talked about this right? Priah--
- I think Priah was--
- Daphne.
I'm Velma--
- You were Velma, almost.
- I was Velma? I thought I'd be--
- I thought it was you were Freddy,
you were Shaggy, I was Velma
and Priah was Daphne.
- I thought he was
Shaggy and I was Scooby.
- Then who's Freddy? He's gotta be Freddy?
- Why does he have to be Freddy?
- Because he's making a plan.
- Yeah.
You're right, you're right.
- Let's split up and look for clues.
- Okay cool.
(dramatic music)
(mouse click)
- I have great memories
of shooting this stuff.
- Me too.
- This was like a really fun day.
- Really fun day.
- This was kind of the first
day that we saw all the
extras also, the Russians.
- Oh yeah, looks like the Death Star.
- Yeah, exactly.
- We got the first tour
of the lab, it was great.
(mouse click)
- Look out, Jesus.
- Man, just how cramped
were all of our legs.
- Oh my god.
- Crouching for a few hours.
- Squats for...
(mouse click)
- You sure?
- Positive. The door
was open for a second.
I saw a bunch of lights and
machines and shit in there.
- That could be a
hundred different things.
- I'll take those odds.
(mouse click)
- Okay, there's the Scooby-Doo shot.
- Yeah, really a lot of work went into
making sure all our heads
were in the right place.
- I went out way farther than it was.
(suspenseful music)
- Alright. We're gonna move
fast, we're gonna stay low,
okay?
- Okay.
- How we would ever get away with all this
is just beyond me.
Because we are very--
- Obviously crossing
through the center of the--
(crosstalk)
- Couldn't get out the
chunk of dialogue we needed
to get out so we had to keep moving.
- Oh I remember that.
- I mean also this--
- The sneaking behind the golf cart--
- - How would we all fit
behind this little thing?
- - And how does that guy not see us?
(laughter)
- Let's go.
- Shh, come on.
- This is George.
- From Russia, him and his family
joined the circus.
Actually.
- That's so true. Nice.
- That was one of the coolest
stories I've ever heard.
- Yeah, he'd had a long family saga right?
- Yeah.
- But the circus--
- He was back in Russia,
and in the 90s they joined the circus.
- (in Russian)
- I had to work on my
Russian speaking so hard.
- You're Russian is very good.
I'm not Russian, but it sounds right.
- [Gaten] It sound very good.
(laughter)
- It sounds alright?
Well we had the Russian consultant on set
who couldn't speak English very well.
It was a difficult, yeah.
- George said you did a job with it.
- Oh, that's nice.
- And if George said you did a good job--
- Then that's probably a
solid, solid thumbs up.
- (in Russian)
- I say, "the secret code."
- [Joe] Yeah the joke is that--
- And then I separate this out,
and I separate in into little pieces.
- I know that you end it with, "China?"
- Yeah, I end with, "China."
- (in Russian)
(yells)
- Oh, I was very hoarse
because of this yelling.
(yells)
(grunts)
(crash)
- That's not you, is it?
- No, you did this all yourself.
- Is that you?
- Yeah.
- What?
- I did all this stuff, yeah.
- Yeah, no stunt guy was involved.
- So fun.
- But all the stuff that
really needs a stunt guy,
like George had to get the heavy hits
and everything like that.
- George did have to get the
heavy hits. Sorry George.
- Sorry George.
- He was in the circus.
(mouse click)
(dramatic music)
(smashing)
- When I hit him on the head,
it's a plastic phone
connected to this cord
and it was made of like foam.
You know you hide the hit and then do it
in front of his face in
such a way that it looks
like you're hitting.
But then the stunt man,
he's actually hitting
his head on the desk.
And he hits it hard, I mean you can see
that's not a joke.
That is like a hard, actual hit.
- That's a hard it.
- So, ow.
But they get paid to do it.
Each time they do it
I think they get paid.
So they're like you wanna do it again?
(laughter)
He's like, "Oh yeah, let's
do it one more time."
Make sure we do it one more time.
- Dude. You did it!
You won a fight.
(mouse click)
- Won a fight. Thanks man.
(claps)
Appreciate it.
- How long did it take
to choreograph that?
- We did it on the day I'm pretty sure.
That was a really fun day.
- That was a tiring day.
- Yeah.
- What are you doing?
- Getting us our ticket out of here.
- You want to walk all the way back?
- Oh no we can hang out for a little bit,
relax, have a picnic maybe.
- Have a picnic? We
came here for the radio.
- [Dustin] If I knew Steve
could knock out a Russian,
that would've been our
plan in the first place.
- Oh I remember this.
- This shot is so beautiful.
- It's gorgeous, but like I
remember how tired we were.
- [Maya] Thanks guys.
- Okay last take.
- One more time.
- One more time, one
more time, one more time,
one more time.
(mouse click)
Guys. There's something up there.
(door opens)
- Let's go.
- What am I thinking about.
I'm looking at a bright blue light.
- How far can I stretch my eyeballs?
- Because I was doing
it, and they're like,
"Gaten it's not clear that
you're shocked right now."
Holy shit.
(suspenseful music)
(mouse click)
- They had the camera on this drone--
- The entire set is there.
- They just flew it slowly back,
this is all choreographed.
- [Gaten] And this set is all there.
The whole chamber.
- Yeah this is all there,
this is all real.
(mouse click)
(dramatic music)
(electrical noises)
- Remember when you saved my life?
- Oh when you almost fell--
- I almost fell off the--
- Where that thing is.
- Oh my god.
- There was like gaps in
the thing where the laser
was supposed to be.
And she nearly--
- I took a foot off of it
(Joe whistles)
And Joe just action-packed hero style just
grabbed me and pulled me back.
- You ever so lightly stepped off.
It wasn't like a fall, it was like--
- It was like about to be that.
(laser noises)
- Whoaaa.
- And that was all a
blue screen right there.
That entire section of wall.
- No no that was real, they
really shot a big laser.
(laughter)
The only thing that's really the effects
is the laser and then the glass.
And then obviously the big--
- Obviously the big giant
gash in the universe.
- The big gate.
- Very death-starry. Very death-starry.
- Lord of the Rings, Sauron situation.
- It does look like Sauron, yeah.
(laser noises)
In the radio room set, you run up there
and then you just look out
over the rest of the set.
And it's just like--
- So beautiful.
- Just plywood stacked
up in this giant castle.
- It's just a shell.
- It's just a shell but it's
basically the entire lab.
Looking out over that is really cool,
one of my favorite spots.
- I hope you guys enjoyed going through
this scene shot-by-shot.
We really enjoyed filming it.
- Check it on, it's out now on Netflix.
- Hope you enjoy it.
(dramatic music)